anybody following what's going on in
Hollywood with the strikes are you are
you who has no clue what's going on in
Hollywood with strikes okay this is
pretty big uh Ron Perlman who played
Hellboy he played in Hellboy and what's
the other one he was and he uh he was in
Beauty and the Beast back in 1987 he was
the Beast and then the other character
was who uh bran what was it Sons of
Anarchy Sons of Anarchy okay so Ron
Perlman makes a video and he calls out
this man that's making 27 million
dollars a year right now guys in
Hollywood it's absolute shambles May 11
500 people right from the writer's guilt
went on strike which means rap if you
want to go on Google YouTube right now
11 500 writers went on strike in May the
last time Jimmy Fallon has done an
episode was in May the last time Stephen
Colbert did an episode was in May the
last time Jimmy Kimmel did an episode
was in May because there is no writer so
go on YouTube and go to Jimmy Jimmy
Fallon's episode it's the best of it's
the best of it's the best of two months
no shows right no movies no shows no
streaming nothing everybody's on
lockdown then this week July 14th 150
000 members from sag went on strike so
now there's a 160
1 500 people in Hollywood who are not
working and by the way if you're part of
Sac you can't have another job so for
example we were inviting Rob who were we
inviting here that said you can't James
Woods James Wood said I can't work I'm
part of sex so he can't even come on the
podcast to speak because that's
considered James's Camp emailed Rob back
saying I can because I'm part of sex so
watch this while this is going on
Hollywood has got all these issues Ron
Perlman and others respond but his one
is the most entertaining one uh brace
for impact there's a lot of curse words
but he's talking about somebody and I'll
highlight to you who he's talking about
go ahead
thing before I get office
the [__]
who said we're going to keep this thing
going until people start losing their
houses in their Apartments
listen to me [__]
there's a lot of ways to lose your house
some of it is financial some of it is
karma
and some of it is just figuring out who
the [__] said that and we know who said
that
and where he [__] lives
there's a lot of ways to lose your house
you wish there are people
you wish that family starve while you're
making 27 [__] million dollars a year
for creating nothing
be careful [__] be really
careful
because that's the kind of [__] that
stirs [__] up
peace out obviously he held back from
you know really shown his emotions which
was very Noble of him definitely
restrained so we're sitting there
figuring out who does 27 million dollar
guy he's talking about so type in uh I
go online I'm like I'm thinking he's
talking about this guy we Google Kelly
we're in the room it's me you and who
Brandon right we're in the room uh was
Maverick in there more it was Mike in
the room one of the guys Mike was
Maverick was in the room Bambi yes so we
Google check this out
Bob iger's income last year type in Bob
Iger made 27 million dollars last
oh wow so he's calling out bye-bye look
at that so then Bob Iger had an
interview with CNBC that we go and find
we're not going to play it for you
because it's three four minutes long I
just kind of paraphrased what he said he
says look it's a shame what they're
doing right now because there's a lot of
people that are relying for jobs and
they got to go out there and do this and
they got to go out there and do that and
these guys have they have to live in
their homes have to pay their rents they
have to pay their mortgages so he's
talking about Bob Iger the CEO of Disney
making 27 million years so now
question that becomes okay so where do
they go from here with everything that's
going on in Hollywood watch some of the
stats on what's going on in Hollywood by
the way
we sat there it's me the group and I
said you know what I want to know let's
look at box office numbers if you can
pull up back Hollywood box office
numbers statista was a statistic of Pew
research statista Hollywood box office
World box office numbers uh statista
right there click on that one it should
be 2019 should be 43 billion no go to
the other chart that actually well you
can use that one zoom in a little bit
zoom in a little bit zoom in no this is
not the one it's another one Brandon if
you can text Rob when he finds it go
back uh maybe go to the second one that
could be the one yeah go to that one
right there I think this is the one
Perfect Look at nine look at the uh 2005
Global box office go up so people can
see what the top Tyler says Global box
office revenue from 2005 to 2021. in
2005 Global box office was 23.1 billion
in 2019 it's 42.3 billion every year
it's going up boom covet happens drops
to 11.8 then it goes to 21.3 and last
year was only 25 billion dollars just so
you guys know we haven't gone back to 42
billion dollars yet fine no problem now
watch the other the other part we're
having this conversation
the discussion becomes you know Kelly
says Pat how do you feel about this you
know how do you feel about this I said
I'll never forget
uh the gentleman that was buying the
company Tom you'll remember this call
he says Patrick we have agreed on this
number he and I talk on the phone he
says the next three to six months
there's only going to be one Community
that's going to ruin this from becoming
a reality and it's the lawyers
your lawyers my lawyers are going to
fight and they're going to make this
deal not happen every time it gets to
the point when the deal doesn't happen
you and I get on gotta get on the phone
to get us so no problem so you know
who's lower screwed it up first Tom
whose lawyer was it you can say it it's
our lawyer our lawyer day one on a zoom
with all their lawyers blasts all of
them
you guys don't know what the [__] you're
doing or that I'm like so I get the call
Pat you won't even believe we were on
December was the most uncomfortable Zoom
our lawyer did this so okay I'll give
him a week maybe he's going to cool off
he had a bad day second day same thing
third name form anyways eventually we
have to get on a call because this
Deal's not going to happen
Union in the middle right now is what's
ruining Hollywood Union in the middle is
getting these guys to do what they're
doing the guys at the top of all these
big companies are making the money
unions holding hostage because they're
asking for lots and well what about this
and what about that one part of the side
that the talent does have a proper
argument because this is you know
they're scanning actors right now and
once they're scanning your uh your body
they can use it without giving you
credit the end of the movie Flash have
you guys seen a movie Flash with your
kids the end of the movie Flash they're
using Dead characters and they have it
in there through CGI but they're not
paying that person
so essentially these guys are saying
wait a minute you're using my likeness
my body I should get paid some are
saying 100 I can see the debate being
maybe they pay you 10 they pay you 20
maybe they pay you 30 but it can't be
free it's me you can't do that pay me
Mike so there's good arguments there but
at the same time AI well we don't want
you to use a all this other stuff then
we wrapped it up with this and I want to
get your thoughts on this
I said let's go and measure the top 100
greatest movies of all time
what is the most credible source to go
to give me the website that we can trust
what is it IMDb perfect we went to IMDb
do you know the top 100 greatest movies
of all time
what decade had the most most uh movies
as a top 100 greatest movies
80s or 90s I think it was 50s was first
huh I want to say six was it 60s first
no I was
yeah so I think I think it was 50 60 70s
then it went to 30s 40s and then it was
tied with 90s 1080s and then in 2000 was
only three movies in the top 100 the
three movies were The Pianist if you've
seen it if you haven't it's a phenomenal
movie then it was Gladiator and I think
the other one was Lord of the Rings that
was from 2000. do you know in the last
20 years 23 years without the technology
with all the CGI with all the Photoshop
all the stuff that they have they've
only produced three movies that are in
the top 100 greatest movies of all time
why well I think there might be a direct
relation between that because sometimes
you know when you go and watch these old
movies when they had none of that what
you needed to have was a great movie
story you know because you had to have a
great story because otherwise it's like
there's nothing else to do with this
whereas now you can really just like it
becomes a crutch just crazy action
scenes and crazy things like that that
aren't you know might be enough to get
people to go see the movie but aren't
enough for them to be like oh this was
like an all-time great it's also look
this whole industry has been like what
we were talking about like the industry
in in uh how people consume news but how
people consume entertainment I mean
we're in the middle of a revolution
nothing short of a revolution like when
I was a kid it was very normal when I
was a kid to not have cable
um like when I was a little kid we were
kind of broke we didn't have cable we
didn't have cable until my mom met my
stepfather and he had cable and I was
like there's more channels what do you
mean but like we had uh mom marry that
guy we had five channels on our TV it
was like there were five channels and
then there was like movie theaters and
that was like entertainment that was
like the only way to get something today
like me and my wife like I really we've
turned on cable maybe five times in the
last year I don't even know why I pay
for it uh we we're always like watching
something on Netflix or on Hulu or on
Amazon or something like that but we now
have not only do you for entertainment
you not only have you have a world of
podcasts and internet shows and all
types of like Services content creators
all types of streaming shows and then
you also have access to the entirety of
Hollywood
all of the history of it right on your
what would be considered movie theater
size TV that you have several of in your
house surround sound so yeah and like
all I mean it's basically almost a movie
experience in most people's living rooms
today so they're they're just tough when
you hit something like 2020 where all of
a sudden nothing's being uh produced
anymore and everybody realizes all of
these other options even once things
kind of reopen up back in 2021 it's like
you're left with this like well I don't
really know if I need to make sure I go
catch the latest movie
on Netflix yeah or Amazon Prime or which
I personally for me like I got two
little kids it's a whole thing for us to
go out to the movies you know what I
mean if there's a movie We want to watch
I kind of much rather find it in the
house anyway like and then we go out and
do something else it's just I think
we're in a revolution in this by the way
it nowadays we're so busy we're watching
movies on 2.0 it's kind of like Titanic
everything's faster well here's a decade
you guys want to know if you can put
this up so people can see it I don't
know if you guys can see it or not uh so
the number one decade was the 50s wow
then it went to 70s tights uh 60s and
90s were tied then 40s 30s then 1980s
and the last place is 2000s for movies I
literally only go to the movies when pbd
does a valuetainment field trip when we
go see uh air what was the last one air
right I saw air or I saw the sound of
Freedom thank you Matt's Apollo for that
recommendation but I also think that
like I don't even know what's in the
movie theaters these days but it's like
Fast and Furious 57 or Harry Potter 19
or Avengers 417 I think it's just the
same nonsense over and over and over and
over again but but by the way did you
watch the last fashion the Furious movie
no have you watched Dave the last time I
don't think I I don't think I've ever
seen a full Fast and Furious movie the
new character they have interesting
individual so you're the guy watching
the movie there it is yeah that's why I
asked you if you watched it so let's
talk about sounds of Freedom so by the
way a big part of what's going on as
well when you think about all of this is
the ESG requirements which you have to
add in the movies you're forcing people
into these movies you have to have a
certain amount of number of people part
of lgbtq you know right now in Hollywood
to be nominated for Oscars you have to
have a certain amount of disabled people
working on a movie
yep you guys haven't it's cool did you
hear what I just said or no yes okay can
you please pull up the new guidelines to
be nominated for Oscars to show
everybody what the guidelines are you
have to be
did you did you actually hear what I
just said you gotta have a gay you gotta
have a [__] you gotta have a trans you
gotta have a black guy that turned into
a [__] that wasn't formerly gay like
there's so much d-e-i-e-sc can there
just be like can there be one person who
fits all of the like one
just like one black gay trans [__] who
we can just put in every movie just for
like he's a high-speed actor by the way
but just like for once
728 million dollars this year and then
but then we're just like they're covered
you guys taking all the jobs
can you pull up the guideline here's the
guideline just so you guys if you wanted
to know so moving forward a at least one
lead actor significant supporting actor
has to be from underrepresented racial
ethnic group or specific country or
territory production that may include a
rap go a little bit to the right because
Adam's foot is not letting me go the
other way the other way what's the other
way there you go
African-American black African Caribbean
descent East Asian uh Hispanic Latino
indigenous people Middle Eastern North
African Pacific Islander
everything except white men Jesus
we get it everyone else
and then by the way here's the other
part here's the other part here's the
other part watch this at least 30 of all
the can you highlight that part I'm
reading at least 30 of all actors on
secondary and more minor roles are from
at least two underrepresented group
which may include women racial or I
think lgbtq and watch the last one
people with cognitive or physical
disabilities who are deaf or hard of
hearing
what
by the way the new guidelines hear me
out the new guidelines the last I think
50 movies that one movie there the Oscar
none of them would have won based on
these guidelines that's the direction
Hollywood is gone read A3 can you
continue with A3 go forward but what the
main storyline storyline subject the
main storyline theme or Narrative of the
film centered on underrepresented groups
women racial ethnics lgbtq people with
cognitive same exact thing as well so if
you like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]